for all of you that have been following
the symbolic World supporting symbolic
world you know that we have been through
quite a bit of Madness regarding the
website you know I wanted to revamp the
website revamp the uh The Branding for
the symbolic world you know I wanted to
bring a forum a community and uh you
know emphasize the Articles there's a
lot of stuff I wanted to do we did that
but then everything started going crazy
we never got the form we wanted then
when we migrated everything vanished all
the content started just disappeared the
article didn't work and so all of this
craziness led us to find a another
person another group to work with and we
started working with a wonderful group
called residents that have just been
amazing and bringing together this new
website which I'm very excited to show
you now so this is the new website and
so on the on the new website as you see
it looks very similar to the the one
that we had before you know you have the
different sections at the outset on the
front page there will be some
differences of course as you can see
even down here we're already hinting at
the new course on Beowulf that uh
Richard Roland will be putting together
with me that we will be making available
on the website we want to do a lot more
of that going doing deep dive symbolism
with different people with myself or
different partners uh so so to really
kind of Dive In
and so when you get to the front page
you'll notice that the content we have
articles podcasts which are basically
the videos or the podcasts but we also
added the reading list
which people we had taken out of the
last version of the website and people
really wanted to bring back and so in
the reading list you we have an
augmented version with uh added books
you know separated into categories we
also added a friends of the symbolic
World different people that I've worked
with that I've collaborated with that
are Akin or you know running parallel
ideas to what we're doing you'll
recognize all of these names here and of
course some resources like the Orthodox
art Journal that I wrote hundreds of
articles for a long time ago but that
are still there and I'm still somewhat
involved with that
um and then you know like the Exodus
series with Jordan Peterson which is
quite popular uh list of universal
history with Richard Roland so all of
that is there in terms of the content
you'll notice that what we've done is
we've added the content directly into
all the content directly into the
podcast section which means that even
the the patron only videos will be
appearing here and they'll have a little
premium sign here and so once you're
signed in if you're supporting the
symbolic world then it'll be easier to
find premium content you'll just go into
the content you can just click on it and
if you're logged in you have access to
it because I know it was complicated to
go through emails and go through all the
stuff to find the premium content now it
will be completely available we will be
organizing all this by tags so if you
want to know did I ever talk about this
you know did Jonathan talk about this
it'll be easier to find and with the
search engine as well so in terms of the
articles with the latest website so many
of the Articles vanished everything with
chaos and so thank you to Cormac Jones
and to JP maxo for working hard with all
the people who had written the Articles
to start putting them back onto the
website and so I think they're all there
and if there's a few missing they will
be coming back up very soon as some of
you might know JP has been working
managing the blog for years now doing an
amazing job uh he's married now you know
a lot of things are going on in his life
and so uh so Cormac Jones is taking over
and JP will still be around writing
articles and doing the French podcast
with me and so that's a great thing
that's going on now the big thing that's
been added to the website is of course
the community
when you click on community if you are
logged in you will come to the the
circle app that is integrated into the
website circle is a wonderful app and
it's kind of like Facebook but uh it'll
be our own Community people can come in
create profiles you can message
privately uh you can write comments on
the Articles within Circle we can create
groups meeting groups all this stuff is
going to be available and this is where
I'm going to focus my energy uh you know
if we're going to try to create surprise
events where people can just sign up and
show up to the event so if you're if
you're signed up to the symbolic world
at any level then you will have access
to this
all right let's go back
all right let me just log out so that
you can see what it looks like
when you come on the first time so when
you come on and you're logged out if you
go to community it will ask you to sign
up to become a member at different
levels
same thing if you go to subscribe and so
the membership is now there are
different levels we have everybody that
wants to receive the newsletter to be
part of the community Forum uh just has
to kind of sign up to the website and so
there is a free subscriber which has
access to community post post to the
community discussions if I do surprise
events on the community people can can
show up for that uh you also get the
newsletter and then we have the
different tiers of support the five
dollar tier has access to the monthly
Patron only video also the Q a which has
been made Patron only to be able to
manage it properly and you can show up
live you can ask your questions uh and I
interact with the chat a lot more now
that it's private and I answer questions
in the chat so for people who support it
ten dollars or more people can then
submit q a questions in advance and we
of course filter them because there's
too many but I do end up answering about
50 questions per per uh q a we tried to
to find the questions that haven't been
asked too many times in the past and
that are the most relevant and then I
can answer your questions on the Q a now
for the 25 a month what I'm going to be
doing is having once once a year a
meeting with about four people will open
slots you can sign up to the different
slots it'll give you a chance to ask me
questions in person have a discussion
all right so we'll have a one hour
meeting uh with three other people uh
with you to uh to discuss whatever it is
you want to discuss uh you can sign up
for fifty dollars a month to get two
meetings a year and then in the top here
is what we have is a a for 150 a month
doctor of symbolism you have twice a
year a one-on-one a zoom call with me
for 30 minutes
for at the 300 level then it's once a
month where you get a 30 minute phone
call people use that to kind of to deal
with some of the let's say some of the
deeper issues they have with symbolism
or sometimes if they want to talk about
a project they're doing you know I have
people that have signed up for this to
uh work on screenplays to work on their
novel their ideas and so during the
conversation you kind of tell me your
idea and uh and then we can we can
discuss about it or you know whatever it
is you want to talk about that's part of
that discussion and the in the two top
tiers we also get a monthly 60-minute
seminar where really then you know you
get me unplugged we talk a lot more
about what's going on in the news what's
going on in the media you know uh let's
say we don't record those discussions
and so I'm more unfiltered and uh just
it's a more direct conversation about
about uh what's going on in the world
let's say and so once you you want to
you can sign up and you can pick the
different tier years if you're already
subscribed which I am you will go to
this part here on the right when you
arrive at login if you are already a
user of patreon or the old website or
subscribe star you have a very simple
way to now connect your account we have
all your emails uh through the different
platforms and so all you need to do is
Click connect your account you write
your email you get a link to reset your
password to set up a new password for
the new website and you're done you're
in we have everything we need and you
will immediately access the website at
the tier that you are supporting me at
and so the people at residence that have
done a great job in making this kind of
simple streamlined it won't be
complicated just one email and you're
back in and so
what you do is once you have your
account you sign in
and so once you are logged in you know
you can have access to your account of
course your membership and you can see
what your membership tier is for
everybody who signs up to the symbolic
World a different uh levels you will
have a few gifts that we're giving even
if you just sign up for free the have a
pdf version of the secrets of God's dog
we're also giving uh
uh free Patron only video that I made
called the primordial importance of
stupid people and an exclusive article
that will be published in the book next
year for Richard Roland on God's dog and
how it fits in what I call the new
apocalyptic storytelling so all this
will be available if you just signed up
for our
um just even just for the newsletter and
so once you are signed in then of course
you can go to the community and you will
access directly into
the circle Community where you can set
up your own profile and everything and
you will also be able to go directly to
the content the content if you go to
podcast and there you will be able to
see all the exclusive videos with a
little premium sign and so if you are
signed up at a paying level you can just
click on those and you will have access
to the patron only content it'll make it
easier to find stuff because I know it
was difficult to get it go through old
emails and kind of you know go through
threads on patreon or whatever and this
will make it a lot easier for you to be
able to follow and so so stay tuned
there's a French version that's also be
will be coming soon with uh the the
podcast and the blog uh so many things
are in the pipeline where soon we will
announce the crowdfunding for the Snow
White uh and the uh uh and the Widow
Queen soon we will also uh be announcing
God's dog 2 that is in the works and uh
as you notice the whole branding for the
symbolic world this this beautiful new
branding was done by Heather pollington
who I'm going to be collaborating with
more and more she's an amazing artist
and I'm really excited about this new
branding we'll be making a video
explaining the symbolism of why it is we
have this this kind of dragon monster
with Birds on it but I'm sure if you've
been following me for a while you
already kind of understand what it is
that's going on there so everybody thank
you for your support you know thanks for
following us all through these difficult
times but I think we're on the way out
and we are soon to have a almost like a
new beginning for the symbolic world so
I will see you soon in the symbolic
World community in our own Forum thanks
everybody bye-bye